สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้
วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วันเสาร์
ใช่วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 10 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
ธันวาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
202 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 9 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนธันวาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 11 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
ธันวาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้กี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
ตี 3
ตี 3 กี่นาที
50 นาที
ตี 3:50 นนะคะก็ตี 3 ยังเป็นเวลากลางคืน
อยู่เนาะเวลาตี 3 เวลากลางคืนแบบนี้ครู
หญิงครูฟ้ายังไม่นอนเพราะว่าเราจะมาเล่า
นิทานให้นักเรียนฟังกันใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าเรา
จะมาเล่านิทานให้นักเรียนฟังกันเหรอคะครู
หญิง
ไม่ได้ค่ะครูฟ้าง่วงนอนไม่ได้ครูฟ้าต้อง
เล่านิทานก่อนครูฟ้าเล่านิทานเสร็จไปเลย
ค่ะไปนอนเลย
ค่ะครูหญิงครูชื่ออะไรคะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะเล่านิทานให้ครูหญิงฟังก็
ได้
แล้ววันนี้ครูฟ้าจะมาเล่านิทานแบบงงๆอ่ะ
นะคะที่แบบไม่ค่อยมี Point อะไรเนี่ย
เรื่องอะไรให้ครูหญิงกับนักเรียนฟังคะ
ชื่อเรื่องนะคะนิทานเรื่องนี้มีชื่อ
เรื่องว่า
สีเขียว
ไม่ใช่วงกลมไม่ใช่แว่นตา Harry  Potter
กบ
ไม่เห็นเก่งจัง
ก็สีเขียวผู้หญิงก็คิดแล้วมันต้องเป็นกบ
แน่ๆเลยผู้หญิงรู้ตั้งแต่ครูฟ้าใช้สี
เขียวแล้วค่ะแต่แค่ไม่อยากพูดเอ้านัก
เรียนคะนี่คือกบนะคะกบ
นิทานเรื่องกบ
กบก็มีขานะคะมีตัว
แล้วก็มี
อันนี้ปีกหรือเปล่าคะ
บินได้หรอกบบินได้หรอ
นี่คือนิทานเรื่องกบเลือกนาย
กบมีเจ้านายด้วยเหรอคะเจ้านายก็คือบอสของ
เราอ่ะนะ
ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยเวลาที่เราทำงานมัน
ก็จะมีแบบนี้ใช่ไหมเวลาในออฟฟิศเนี่ยแล้ว
ก็จะมีครูหญิง
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าครูหญิงนี่ไงอันนี้เราเนี่ย
ทำงานคนนี้เป็นนายของเรา
แล้วก็ครูหญิงก็มีลูกน้องลูกน้องลูกน้อง
อันนี้ก็เป็นนายใช่ไหมเราจะดูแบบนี้ใช่
ไหม
ใช่
หรอคะ
กบเนี่ยอยากมีเจ้านายผู้หญิงแต่กบก็เลือก
หรอครูฟ้าเลือกไหมเวลาเลือกเจ้านายไหมไม่
นะเจ้านายเนี่ยเลือกเราเราเลือกเจ้านาย
ไม่ได้นะคะครูฟ้าไม่เอามิสเตอร์เอเป็น
เจ้านายค่ะคุณฟ้าไม่ชอบเพราะเลือก
มิสเตอร์บีนเป็นเจ้านายได้ไหม
ไม่ได้ค่ะแต่มิสเตอร์เอบอกว่าไม่เอาครู
ฟ้าเป็นลูกน้องเอาครูหญิงดีกว่าเลือกครู
หญิงไม่เลือกครูฟ้าอันนี้ได้เจ้านายเนี่ย
เลือกเราได้แต่เราเลือกเจ้านายไม่ได้แล้ว
กบเป็นใคร
ทำไมมาอยู่ดีๆมันเลือกนายเป็นยังไงคะอยาก
ฟังแล้วก็อยากรู้จังเลยว่าทำไมกบถึงเลือก
นายแล้วกบเนี่ย vip มาจากไหนทำไมถึงเลือก
นายได้อยากรู้ไหมคะนักเรียน
ผู้หญิงย้ายกบเป็นครูฟ้าได้ไหมคะ
ฟ้า
เล็กอ่ะถ้าเส้นเล็กเราย้ายได้ป่ะเอ้าผู้
หญิง
ผู้หญิงฉลาดอ่ะ
นางฟ้าทำไม่ได้นะคะ
คุณฟ้ากดตรงเส้นเล็กไง
ไม่มีค่ะมีเมาส์หรอ
มีไหมคะ
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะผู้หญิงเลือกย้ายให้ได้ค่ะ
คุณฟ้า
ขอบคุณค่ะ
นี่ไม่ใช่กบแล้วค่ะนี่คือเอเลี่ยน
นักเรียนบอกว่าเออ
ช่วยอ่ะโอเคค่ะ
ได้แล้วขอบคุณค่ะ
มีทะเลสาบ
dead  sea
มีทะเลสาบนะทะเลสาบ dead  sea ทะเลสาบ
มิชิแกน
นะคะที่สกอตแลนด์อันนี้อะไรคะที่ทะเลสาบ
อะไรเขียวๆเนี่ย
ใบบัว
ฝรั่งมีดอกบัวด้วยหรอ
ไม่รู้ค่ะแต่ว่ากบมันอยู่ข้างบนไง
ใบไม้หรอ
ใช่ไหม
ในทะเลสาบเนี่ยมันก็จะมีต้นไม้มีดอกไม้มี
ต้นหญ้า
มันก็จะมีใบ
ใบไม้อยู่ข้างบนนะคะกบเนี่ยอยู่บนใบไม้ใน
ทะเลสาบ
อยู่บนใบไม้อ้าว
อยู่บนกบ
ต้องอยู่บนใบไม้สิ
นี่
นักเรียนเลย
กบเนี่ยอยู่บนใบไม้นะคะเราบอกว่ามีกบอยู่
ฝูงนึงอันนี้กบ 1 ตัวใช่ไหม 1 ตัว
[เพลง]
แล้วกบฝูงมึงเนี่ยมัน
กลบกลุ่มนึงไหมครูฟ้า
สูงค่ะ
สูงเหรอ
มีกี่ตัวคะครูฟ้า
กบถุงนึงก็อาจจะมีประมาณ
20 ตัว
กบกบ 1 ตัว 2 ตัว 3 ตัว 4 ตัว 5 ตัวยี่
สิบตัวเราพูดว่ากบ
ฝูงนึงนะคะ
กบฝูงนึง
[เพลง]
กบเนี่ยก็อยู่ด้วยกันแบบมีความสุขนะคะ
Happy
อยู่ด้วยกันอย่างมีความสุขแล้วก็ DNA
เอาไว้ตรงกลางนะคะแล้วค่ะเรื่องสิคะครู
ฟ้า
นักเรียนยังไม่จบกบเนี่ยจริงๆก็อยู่ด้วย
กันแบบมีความสุขนะคะแล้วก็มีอยู่วันนึงกบ
ก็คุยกัน
คุยอะไรกันคะครูฟ้า
กบเนี่ยอยากจะมี
พระราชาของกบค่ะ
แต่ว่าเป็นพระราชาที่เป็นกบ
เพราะว่ากบเนี่ยอยู่ด้วยกันแล้วรู้สึกว่า
กบในอยากมีเจ้านายไง
อ๋อคือเหมือนอยู่กัน 20 ตัวแต่ว่าไม่มี
ใครเป็นเจ้านายก็ไม่รู้จะฟังใครอย่างนี้
หรอก็เลยอยากมีพระราชาก็เลยอยากมีพระราชา
นะคะกบก็เลยคุยกันว่าเออเราน่าจะมีพระ
ราชามาดูแลพวกเรานะ
เป็นอะไรก็ได้ค่ะที่เป็นพระราชา
แล้วยังไงต่อคะ
ก็เลยมีกบตัวนึงเนี่ยนะคะไป
ไหว้เทพเจ้า
ไปหาเทพจูปิเตอร์ค่ะ
เทพจูปิเตอร์นี่เก่งอะไรคะ
แทบจูปิเตอร์ก็คือทรุดนะคะ
แต่ว่าชุดเนี่ยเป็นภาษาอังกฤษ
นะคะ
จูปิเตอร์ก็โอเคค่ะก็เลยเอาอันนี้มาค่ะ
คุณหญิงอะไรคะครูฟ้าลบเทพจูปิเตอร์ออกไป
ท่อนไม้หรอ
ขอนไม้
ขอนไม้ให้ขอนไม้เป็นพระราชากบเหรอใช่ให้
คนไม้เป็นพระราชาของกบแล้วกบโอเคไหมให้
ขอนไม้เป็นพระราชากบก็ดีใจตื่นเต้นตื่น
เต้นดีใจดีใจนะคะแล้วก็ขึ้นมาอยู่ข้างบน
นี้ใช่ไหม
กบ
ทั้งหมดก็เลยมาอยู่บนขอนไม้อย่างนี้หรอ
ใช่กบก็มาอยู่บนขอนไม้แล้วก็เต้นร้องเพลง
อยู่บนขอนไม้นี่นะคะ
เป็นเวลาประมาณ 7 วัน
แล้วเป็นยังไงคะ
พอ 7 วันผ่านไป
7 วันผ่านไปเนี่ยกบก็เบื่อค่ะคุณหญิง
แล้วไม่ชอบแล้ว
เบื่อแล้วทำยังไง
กบก็เลยไปหาเทพจูปิเตอร์อีก 1 ครั้ง
ไปหาทำไม
เทพจูปิเตอร์นะคะ
ก็ไปหาเทพจูปิเตอร์อีกไปขอเจ้านายใหม่ไป
ขอพระราชาใหม่หรอให้ไปขอพระราชาใหม่ค่ะ
ครูหญิงไม่เอาขอนไม้แล้ว
คราวนี้เนี่ยจูปิเตอร์ก็เลยส่ง
ส่งอะไรมาให้เป็นพระราชากับกบคะ
อะไรอ่ะปลาไหล
ปลาไหล
ปลาไหลนะคะ
ปลาไหลมันเป็นปลาที่เหมือนงู
ปลาไหลนะ
[ปรบมือ]
ใช่
ปลาไหลเนี่ย Jupiter ก็เลยส่งปลาไหลมา
แต่ปลาไหลเนี่ยพอลงมาแล้วใช่ไหม
เป็นยังไงคะ
มันก็เข้าไปแอบอยู่ในรูค่ะ
ก็ไปแอบอยู่ในรู
เอ้าแล้วทำไมมันไม่ออกมาล่ะ
อาจจะกลัวกบ
แล้วกบโอเคไหมพอได้ปลาไหลมาเป็นพระราชา
แต่ปลาไหลไม่ยอมออกมา
กบไม่โอเคค่ะกบก็เลยมาหาจูปิเตอร์อีก
ครั้งนึง
มาขอพระราชาคนใหม่หรอมาขอพระราชาค่ะ
ไม่ใช่สิ
ไม่ใช่นกอันนี้นะคะนี่คือนกธรรมดานะคะนัก
เรียนแต่ว่ามันจะเป็นนกแบบ
นกอะไรคะครูฟ้านกเงือกประสา
นกกระสาที่ขายยาวๆหรอ
ใช่นกกระสาที่ขาจะยาว
แบบนี้เนาะ
แบบนี้ใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
ปลาไหลให้นักเรียนดูนะคะเจ้านายคนที่แล้ว
เนี่ยนี่เนาะนักเรียนปลาไหลนะคะอ๋อส่งนก
กระสามาแล้วเป็นยังไงต่อคะ
คราวนี้เนี่ยพอนกกระสามาแล้วนะคะ
นกกระสาเนี่ยก็มาที่
เขาเรียกอะไรนะ
ทะเลสาบทะเลสาบ
นะคะเสร็จแล้วนกกระสาก็กินกบ
กินตัวที่ 1 ตัวที่ 2 ตัวที่ 3 ตัวที่ 4
ตัวที่ 5 ตัวที่ 6 กินกบหมดเลยใช่กินกบ
หมดเลยค่ะก็อาจจะกินกบไปประมาณ
15 ตัว
ก็เหลือกบอยู่ 5 ตัว
เหลือกบอยู่ 5 ตัว
อยู่ 5 ตัวแล้วเป็นยังไงต่อคะกบไปหา
จูปิเตอร์อีกไหมเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยนะคะกบก็ไป
หา
กินเข้าไปแล้วแล้วไปบอกอะไรคะ
ขอพระราชาใหม่ได้ไหม
ไม่เอานกกระสาแล้ว
เนี่ยเหลือกบอยู่แค่นี้เอง
แต่จูปิเตอร์เนี่ยก็พูดว่าถ้ากบยังมาขอ
พระราชาขอพระราชาขอพระราชากบอาจจะเจอ
เรื่องไม่ดีอีกเยอะเลยนะ
ทำไมกบไม่ไปอยู่ด้วยกัน
อย่างแฮปปี้ Forever ล่ะ
ไม่ต้องมีพระราชาใช่ไม่ต้องมีพระราชาก็
ได้
แล้วเป็นยังไงต่อคะครูฟ้ากบยังขอพระราชา
อยู่ไหมเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็
จบ
แบบนี้หรอคะ
[เพลง]
ก็คือซุสก็ไม่ให้แล้วบอกกบว่าพอแล้วถ้ากบ
ขออีกมันอาจจะไม่โอเคนะเห็นไหมกบมีขอนไม้
เป็นพระราชาคนที่ 1 ดีแล้วกบก็ไม่ชอบก็มา
เปลี่ยนเป็นปลาไหลแต่ปลาไหลก็ไม่เอา
เปลี่ยนอีกเป็นนกกระสาขายยาวๆ
เห็นไหมนกกระสาก็เลยกินกบหมดเลยเหลืออยู่
5 ตัว
[เพลง]
แล้ว
แล้วฟังจบแล้วเนี่ยนะคะครูฟ้านิทานเรื่อง
นี้สอนอะไรคะ
เราเนี่ยนะคะจะต้อง
โอเคหรือว่าพอใจกับสิ่งที่เรามีค่ะ
ทุกตัวเหมือนกบใช่ไหมคะกบเนี่ยทุกตัวอยู่
ในทะเลสาบอยู่ด้วยกันอย่างมีความสุขแล้ว
แต่กบรู้สึกไม่พอใจไม่โอเคไม่ชอบอยากมี
เจ้านายอยากมีพระราชาแต่เวลาเลือกอันนี้
ไม่เอาอันนี้ไม่ชอบอันนี้เปลี่ยนได้ไหม
เลือกมากๆก็ได้นกกระสามากินเลย
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราก็จะต้องเรามีความสุข
แล้วก็โอเคไม่ขออะไรอีกนะคะไม่อยากได้
อะไรมากขึ้น
ให้มีความสุขกับสิ่งที่เรามีใช่ค่ะ
เหมือนเราอยู่ประเทศไทยร้อนๆแล้วเราบอก
ว่าขอให้ประเทศไทยหนาวๆได้ไหม
ไม่ชอบร้อนๆพอประเทศไทยหนาวๆคนไทยไม่ชิน
กับหนาวๆ
แต่มีความสุข
บางคนเขาก็ไม่ชอบคือไม่ชอบหนาวไง
อะไรนะ Jupiter ก็บอกโอเคให้ประเทศไทย
หนาวขึ้นเพราะฉะนั้นไม่เอาอันนี้หนาวไม่
พอเอาหนาวมากกว่านี้หนาว
[เพลง]
อยู่ไม่ได้เห็นไหมก็นี่ไงคนไทยก็เหมือนกบ
ใช่ไหมตอนนี้
อาจจะพอใจตั้งแต่อย่างที่ 1 ก็ได้นะ
20 องศาใช่ไหมกำลังดีกำลังดีค่ะคนไทยก็
พอใจนะคะคนไทยโอเค
เออสบายใจจริงๆแล้วผู้หญิงก็อยากให้
ประเทศไทยหนาวนะคะปัจจุบัน
[เพลง]
ของครูฟ้านะคะเรื่องกบเลือกนายเนาะส่วน
วีดีโอนี้ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าขอไปหากบกิน
ก่อนนะคะเพราะว่าฟังแล้วหิว
นะครูฟ้างั้นเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ใน
วีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ